damit kommen wir dann zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt da geht es um
Sanktionen die von der Europäischen
Union erlassen werden und wie diese
umgesetzt werden können noch ist die
Durchsetzung von Sanktionen in den
verschiedenen EU-Mitgliedstaaten recht
unterschiedlich und deswegen möchte dort
die Union das noch harmonisieren und
damit der deutsche Vertreter im Rat der
Europäischen Union ist diesem diese
Harmonisierung zustimmen kann braucht es
einen Gesetzentwurf und über diesen
Gesetzentwurf sprechen wir jetzt das ist
die zweite und dritte Beratung des
Gesetzesentwurfes der hier von der
Bundesregierung eingebracht wurde und
der Titel ist Entwurf eines Beschlusses
des Rates über die Feststellung des
Verstoßes gegen restriktive Maßnahmen
der Union als einen die Kriterien nach
Artikel 83 Absatz 1 des Vertrages über
die Arbeitsweise der europ die Union
erfüllenden kriminalitätsbereich das zur
Vollständigkeit halber wie gesagt es
geht um Sanktionen gegen Unternehmen
Gruppen Organisationen oder
Einzelpersonen die zum Beispiel mit
Reisebeschränkungen belegt werden können
deren Vermögenswerte eingefroren werden
können oder zum Beispiel wo es um
Einfuhr oder Ausfuhrbeschränkungen geht
und der erste Redner dazu ist Michael
Sacher von Bündnis 90 die Grünen Frau
Präsident entschuldigen Sie Herr Sacher
das war jetzt zu viel gerade Chaos auf
einmal ich möchte natürlich erwähnen
dass das ihre erste Rede in diesem Hause
ist
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen als dezidierter Nichtjurist
spreche ich hier bei diesem Thema als
überzeugter Europäer und nicht nur als
Mitglied des Ausschusses für europäische
Angelegenheiten als ein überzeugter
Europäer der auch mit Hilfe der
trockenen Rechtsprechung hofft die
Zukunft auf unserem Kontinent und
darüber hinaus friedlich und
prosperierend gestalten zu können
machen
prosperierend ist hier allerdings nicht
in einem herkömmlichen vereinfachten
Sinne mit Wirtschaftswachstum zu
verwechseln sondern weiter darüber
hinaus als am blühendes gedeihen einer
vielfältigen Zivilgesellschaft zu
verstehen
wie schon das Sams in den Büchern von
Paul Maar bei dem Gebrauch von
Wunschpunkten einforderte genauestens
genau zu wünschen so ist das auch auf
dem Feld der Rechtsprechung wichtig und
wesentlich genau zu sein
nachzujustieren wenn sich Probleme bei
der Durchsetzung des gültigen rechtes
zeigen
die Europäische Kommission möchte
erreichen dass sie Verletzungen von
EU-Sanktionen zu Straftaten erklärt
werden um so die Verfolgung effektiver
zu gestalten
wir als Bundestag müssen dem zuvor
zustimmen das Verstöße gegen die von der
EU verhängten Sanktionen in den
kriminalitätsbereich übernommen werden
können
so einfach so gut und darum geht es hier
nicht unwesentlich ist vielleicht der
Hinweis dass Deutschland das letzte
europäische Land ist das hier noch auf
nationaler Ebene zustimmen muss
dies liegt diesmal nicht am langsamen
Internet sondern daran dass wir eines
der wenigen Parlamente sind überhaupt
damit befasst werden ein Zeichen unserer
starken parlamentarischen Demokratie
vor dem Hintergrund des Krieges den
Russland gegen die Ukraine führt ist
diese rechtliche Schwachstelle beim
Sanktionen noch einmal deutlich
hervorgetreten verbunden mit dem Problem
dass eine Harmonisierung des Strafmaßes
in den Mitgliedstaaten von Nöten ist
denn wenn dieses das Strafmaß in den
unterschiedlichen europäischen Ländern
von einigen tausend bis zu mehreren
hunderttausend Euro variiert lässt das
nicht nur Fachleute wie Laien staunen
sondern Zeug nicht gerade von einer gut
aufgestellten einheitlichen
Geschlossenheit
Sanktionen zu verhängen ist das eine sie
aber auch nachhaltig und effektiv
durchsetzen zu können das andere hier
nachzubessern ist notwendig und dringend
geboten
die expertinnenanhörung im Ausschuss hat
das einhellig und deutlich unterstrichen
nicht ohne auf die Schwierigkeiten im
Detail nämlich die Präzisierung zu
verweisen aber diese ist auch erst der
zweite Schritt auf europäischer Ebene
den wir heute durch unsere Beschluss
erst ermöglichen
es geht um eine vernünftige
nachvollziehbare Regulierung jetzt vor
allem rechtlich abgesichert werden muss
damit die Europäische Union in diesem
Punkt international handlungsfähig und
verlässlich bleiben kann
diese Regelung um es knapp zu sagen ist
einfach notwendig und wichtig und nur
der Teufel wird sicherlich noch im
Detail stecken wo zum Beispiel noch die
einzelnen Tatbestände rechtssicher und
wir erinnern uns genauestens genauso
definiert werden müssen
hier seien nur alle in diesem Haus
beruhigt denn diese Ausformulierung wird
erneut hier im Parlament verhandelt und
besprochen und dann erst auf dem
rechtsgültigen Weg gebracht
eingangs ließ sich schon darauf hin dass
ich an überzeugter Europäer bin ein
Umstand auf den hinzuweisen in diesen
Tagen vielleicht wieder notwendiger wird
als alle hier oder fast alle hier
gedacht und gehofft hatten
eine starke Gemeinschaft verträgt
durchaus Unruhen Aggressionen von innen
und außen kann darauf reagieren damit
diskursiv umgehen und nicht nur in der
Europäischen Union hilft Kritik häufig
einfach um besser zu werden so wie
Demokratie nie ein festgefügter
Endzustand ist sondern ein Prozess einen
immerwährendes aushandeln so ist es auch
mit der Europäischen Union
Vielstimmigkeit und Diversität ist dabei
unsere Stärke
stumpf mit dem nationalen Kopf durch die
Wand zu wollen oder vielmehr Fakten frei
mit diesem an die Wand zu schlagen ist
weder eine gute Strategie noch eine
konstruktive Politik
und es tut auch schon meistens beim
Zuschauen weh die Europäische Union wird
beständig von uns neu gestaltet und
hoffentlich Schritt für Schritt
verbessert und in jeweils aktuellen
Gegebenheiten angepasst wenn Kritik aber
in Hass umschläfen alles konstruktive
vermissen lässt und es nicht um eine
Verbesserung sondern einfach nur noch um
die Zerstörung geht dann ist ein Punkt
erreicht wo wir hier in unserem
Parlament in unserem Land in Europa und
in Brüssel für eines der stärksten
friedensprojekte kämpfen müssen
nicht kämpfen wie die Ukraine mit
schweren Waffen gegen einer Aggressor
von außen kämpfen muss sondern von innen
heraus kämpfen mit Überzeugung Fakten
und den Möglichkeiten die ein freies
miteinander bieten
Werte Kollegin nur in einem freien und
diversen miteinander werden wir uns für
eine gelingende Zukunft aufstellen
können in der Europäischen Union in der
wir unsere Konflikte regelbasiert und
ohne einen nationalistisches ich zuerst
lösen können
und manchmal
manchmal sind es eben vermeintlich
kleine juristische Maßnahmen die einen
nicht unwesentlichen Anteil an dem
Gelingen eines großen Kampfes für den
Frieden in Europa haben danke viel
das Wort erhält Katharina dos Santos
Vince für die cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen mit Putins Teil
mobil machen vor einer Woche sowie den
scheinreferenten in den von Russland
besetzten Gebieten hat der russische
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine eine
neue Stufe erreicht als Reaktion darauf
hat die EU-Kommission gestern ein
Vorschlag für ein weiteres
Sanktionspaket gegen Russland vorgelegt
enthalten sind unter anderem weitere
Importbeschränkungen im Wert von um 7
Milliarden Euro sowie die
Rechtsgrundlage für einen preisdeckel
für Ölimporte aus Russland
neben neuen sanktionspaketen bedarf es
aber jedoch vor allem auch endlich eine
effektiveren Durchsetzung der bereits
bestehenden Sanktionen Sophie eine
Ahnung von Verstößen
aktuell bestehen zwischen den
sanktionsregimen der einzelnen
EU-Mitgliedsstaaten signifikante
Unterschiede was deren Wirkkraft
insgesamt deutlich abschwächt so handelt
es sich in einigen Mitgliedsstaaten bei
Verstößen im ordnungswidrigkeitenbereich
in anderen Ländern um schwere Straftaten
die mit langen Freiheitsstrafen geahndet
werden
angesichts dieses unterschiedlichen
Umgangs der Mitgliedsstaaten mit
Sanktionen ist es höchste Zeit dass
sanktionsstrafrechts auf EU-Ebene zu
harmonisieren und so gewisse
Mindeststrafen bei Verstößen in allen
EU-Mitgliedsstaaten zu gewährleisten wir
müssen
wir müssen als EU einheitlich und stark
reagieren können jede Umgehung von
Sanktionen jedes Schlupfloch schwächt
die Sicherheit die Verhandlungsbasis und
letztendlich auch die Reputation der EU
und jedes Mitgliedsstaat selbst
grundsätzlich liegt das Strafrecht in
der Kompetenz der Mitgliedstaaten
allerdings darf die EU nach 83 Absatz 1
AUV Mindestvorschriften von Straftaten
in Strafen mit besonders schwerwiegenden
kriminalitätsbereichen festlegen die
eine grenzüberschreitende Dimension
haben das gilt zum Beispiel schon für
den Bereich der Geldwäsche wodurch
komplexe grenzüberschreitende
Verflechtungen eine länderübergreifende
Strafverfolgung und Zusammenarbeit
sinnvoll und notwendig ist im Mai diesen
Jahres hat die EU-Kommission den
Vorschlag für einen Beschluss des Rates
vorgelegt der auch das
sanktionsstrafrecht umfasst und aufgrund
seiner grenzüberschreitenden Dimensionen
in die Liste der kriminalitätsbereiche
aufzunehmen ist aus meiner Sicht ein
absolut wichtiger und richtiger Schritt
mir ist es an dieser Stelle aber noch
mal wichtig zu betonen dass der Deutsche
Bundestag sich auch in kurzer Zeit
intensiv in dieses Thema eingearbeitet
hat und zu den Themen beraten hat sowohl
in unserer Fraktion als auch in den
entsprechenden Gremien zuletzt gestern
im Europaausschuss und am Montag in der
öffentlichen Anhörung so werden wir
unser
integrationsverantwortung auch deutlich
und umfassend gerecht
der vorgelegte entsetztesentwurf enthält
zur Überraschung vieler auch ein Passus
zum Infektionsschutzgesetz wie kommen
wir jetzt vom AV zum
Infektionsschutzgesetz aufgrund des
omnibus-verfahrens wie in einem Bus
bildlich gesprochen kommt in unserem
Fall ein weiterer Passagier in den Bus
dazu und wir fahren gemeinsam durch
dieses Gesetzgebungsverfahren in diesem
Fall geht es um eine Änderung im
Infektionsschutzgesetz auf Druck der
unionsgeführten Länder hat der Bundesrat
vor zwei Wochen nun entschieden dass
nach einer überstandenen
corona-infektionen keine testpflicht für
Kinder Jugendliche und Beschäftigte bei
der Rückkehr in Schulen Kitas und
Einrichtungen der Kinder- und
Jugendhilfe geben sollen die zu einer
stärkeren Belastung der vorgenannten
Personengruppe geführt hätte Erwachsene
können schließlich auch nach einer
entsprechenden
überstandenen corona-infektion ohne
negativen Test zurück zu ihrem
arbeitsplatzkern wir begrüßen daher
ausdrücklich diese Streichung
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen zurück zu
unserem Gesetzentwurf zu den Sanktionen
wie sieht das weitere Verfahren aus wird
der Beschluss des Rates angenommen kann
die EU-Kommission in einem zweiten
Schritt eine konkrete Richtlinie für
eine EU-weite Mindestharmonisierung von
Sanktionen vorliegen die dann wiederum
die schon erwähnt in nationales Gesetz
und gerecht umgesetzt werden muss wenn
es im nächsten Schritt dann in die
nationale Umsetzung geht ist es mein
Wunsch und Anliegen eine enge Abstimmung
auf nationaler Ebene zwischen der
Mitgliedsstaaten zu fördern und dazu
gehört für mich auch eine enge
Abstimmung unter dem Parlamentariern in
den verschiedenen Foren die wir dafür
haben ein gutes Beispiel und das wäre
mir wirklich ein Herzensanliegen in
dieser Sache ist ein gemeinsamer
Austausch auch mit den französischen
Kollegen in der deutsch-französischen
Parlamentarischen Versammlung in jedem
Fall wird uns dieses Thema auch auf
parlamentarischer Ebene noch eine
längere Zeit begleiten wir sehen uns
also wieder herzlichen Dank
Katharina das Santos Vinz war das für
die Unionsfraktion und nächster Redner
ist Fabian Funke Mitglied der
SPD-Fraktion und Mitglied im Ausschuss
für Angelegenheiten Europäischen Union
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren was hinter diesen
zugegebenermaßen etwas
verwaltungsdeutsch und kompliziert
klingt ein Tagesordnungspunkt steht ist
ein weiteres wichtiges Signal der
Unterstützung der Ukraine gegen den
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg der
Russischen Föderation die letzten Monate
haben gezeigt dass wir gemeinsam als
Europäische Union stark sein können wenn
wir geschlossen agieren das haben wir
bei der politischen Unterstützung der
Ukraine gesehen das haben wir bei der
materiellen Unterstützung der Ukraine
gesehen und das haben wir auch bei den
Sanktionen immer gesehen auch wenn es
manchmal schwer war Einigkeit unter den
Mitgliedsstaaten herzustellen auch weil
die Gegebenheiten und Abhängigkeiten so
unterschiedlich sind hier in Deutschland
haben wir mit dem
sanktionsdurchsetzungsgesetz bereits
national die Voraussetzungen geschaffen
die Vorstöße die Verstöße gegen die
Sanktionen entsprechend zu ahnen mit der
Änderung des Artikel 83 aiuv schaffen
wir sie auch europäisch doch was genau
verbirgt sich dahinter
mit der Befähigung der Bundesregierung
zur Zustimmung der Änderung des Artikel
83 Absatz 1 im Europäischen Rat fügen
wir dem Katalog grenzüberschreitender
europäischer einheitlicher Bekämpfung
von Kriminalität einen neuen
kriminalitätsbereich hinzu Verstöße
gegen die eu-sanktionsbeschlüsse dieser
Schritt ermöglicht uns gemeinsame
europäische Mindeststandards für die
Strafen bei Verstößen gegen die
Sanktionen festzulegen wir werden
Schluss machen mit den Dutzenden
unterschiedlichen nationalstaatlichen
organisierten Sanktionsregime wir legen
das Fundament dafür dass künftig
sanktionsbeschlüsse das Ende nicht der
Anfang von umsetzungsdebatten sind
wir machen dem russischen Region
deutlich hier handeln 27 Staaten von der
Atlantikküste bis zur ukrainischen
Grenze als Einheit die sanktionsverstöße
in den Katalog aufzunehmen ist im
übrigen auch ein mustergültiges Beispiel
für die Anwendung des Artikel 83 denn
sie erfüllen die beiden
ausschlaggebenden Kriterien dafür
außerordentlich sie repräsentieren ein
besonders schweren kriminalitätsbereich
und haben eine grenzüberschreitende
Dimension denn welches Verbrechen könnte
schwerer wiegen als unsere gemeinsamen
Bemühungen zufrieden und Freiheit in
Europa wieder herzustellen und welcher
Tatbestand könnte grenzüberschreitender
sein als beispielsweise mit Verstößen
gegen die Finanzsanktionen
hier bei uns die Kriegsmaschinerie in
Russland zu finanzieren die besondere
Notwendigkeit diese Kriminalität auf
einer gemeinsamen Grundlage zu bekämpfen
ist offensichtlich aber scheinbar nicht
offensichtlich genug denn abgesehen von
der Opposition ganz rechts hier im
Plenum und leider Gottes auch Teilen der
Opposition ganz links im Plenum auf die
ich eigentlich auch gar nicht weiter
eingehen möchte weil es auch nichts
bringt gibt es derzeit ja immer noch
eine laute Stimme auch aus der Mitte
dieses Parteienspektrums
dies auch nach sieben Monaten an
Gräueltaten immer noch nicht verstanden
hat und anders sieht und gerade als
Abgeordneter aus Sachsen ist es mir
deshalb besonders wichtig nochmal
grundsätzlich ein paar Worte zu den
Sektionen und ihre Wichtigkeit zu
verlieren Russland führt seit sieben
Monaten einen Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine die russische Armee begeht
systematisch Kriegsverbrechen gegen die
ukrainische Zivilbevölkerung Russland
finanziert seit Jahren in Europa
rechtsradikale Bewegungen Parteien und
Kandidaten Russland arbeitet aktiv an
der Destabilisierung unserer
freiheitlich demokratischen Grundordnung
durch massive Desinformationskampagnen
die europäischen Sanktionen sind unsere
Reaktion darauf die hohen Gaspreise die
blockierten Lebensmittellieferungen die
versiegelten Pipelines das sind alles
Druckmittel der russischen Regierung mit
der sie nur eins erreichen will dass wir
hier alles durchgehen lassen dass wir
nicht mal den Versuch unternehmen unsere
Demokratie zu verteidigen doch darauf
lassen wir uns nicht ein die
Energiekrise die Preiserhöhungen die
gestörten Lieferketten das alles ist die
Konsequenz des russ der Handels und
nicht die Konsequenz unserer Reaktion
darauf wir reagieren mit
entlastungspaketen und der
gaspreisbremse um die Folgen für unsere
Bevölkerung abzufedern Liebe CDU ich
bedanke mich bei Ihnen ausdrücklich für
die konstruktive Zusammenarbeit im
Bereich der Ukraine Hilfe und auch die
Unterstützung dieser Beschlussempfehlung
sowohl bei der Anhörung im Munde am
Montag als auch im Ausschuss aber
erklären Sie mir bitte wie so ein
amtierender christdemokratischer
Ministerpräsident und stellvertretender
Parteivorsitzender die Sanktionen
mittlerweile nahezu täglich und
ausgiebig in Interviews und öffentlichen
Auftritten in Frage stellt mit einem
Duktus der aussagt man müsse am Ende nur
mal richtig dem Diplomatie machen und
dann wird alles wieder in Ordnung das
ist naiv und falsch
das schwächt die deutsche Position in
Europa das schwächt die europäische
Position gegenüber Russland und das
sorgt dafür dass ich Putin nachts im
kremme ins Häuschen macht auch die
schlimmen Äußerung ihres fraktions- und
Parteivorsitzenden Friedrich Merz in
dieser Woche die ich ehrlich gesagt von
der AFD erwartet hätte aber nicht von
ihnen haben das nicht besser gemacht
gerade in Ostdeutschland wissen wir was
Autokratie und fremdbestimmungen aus
Moskau bedeutet die Stasi Enteignung und
fehlende Grundrechte das alles kam aus
dem Handbuch Moskau in ich erwarte von
einem sächsischen Ministerpräsidenten
erst recht wenn er offenkundlicher für
ganz Ostdeutschland sprechen möchte dass
er in dieser aktuellen Lage Solidarität
mit unseren zentralen und
osteuropäischen Partnern zeigt mit denen
wir so viel mehr historischer
Gemeinsamkeiten Teilen ich freue mich
dass seine und ihre Parteifreundinnen
kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
gestern das nächste Sanktionspaket
vorgelegt hat und ich habe großes
Vertrauen in die Bundesregierung dass
wir die Bürgerinnen und Bürger im
kommenden Winter weiter von den Effekten
putins-
werden wir schaffen das nur gemeinsam in
Europa zu guter Letzt noch ein paar
Worte zur Änderung des § 34
Infektionsschutzgesetz der ja jetzt auch
Teil dieses Tagesordnungspunktes ist mit
diesem Änderungsantrag kommen wir der
breit getragenen bitte der Bundesländer
nach die testlicht für Schulkinder nach
einer corona-infektion zu streichen mit
der Aufnahme in diesem Gesetzentwurf
stellen wir auch sicher dass die
Änderung pünktlich die
bundesratssitzungen am 7.12.2022
erreicht und das ist gut so vielen Dank
Fabian Funke Warner ist für die
SPD-Fraktion auf ihn folgt nun Fabian
Jacobi Mitglied der afd-fraktion und im
Ausschuss für Recht und
Verbraucherschutz
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
das man keine Krise ungenutzt
vorbeigehen lassen sollte das ist ein
alter und allgemein anerkannter
Grundsatz auch die EU hat sich diesem
Prinzip verschrieben zuletzt hat man die
Krise der sogenannten Pandemie genutzt
um unter ihrem Deckmantel das
Verschuldungsverbot der EU zu kippen
seitdem nimmt die EU selber Schulden auf
für die am Ende die Mitgliedstaaten und
natürlich vor allem Deutschland haften
jetzt haben wir die Krise des russischen
Krieges gegen die Ukraine und auch diese
bleibt natürlich nicht ungenutzt
vielmehr dient sie als willkommener
Vorwand um den Parlamenten der
Mitgliedsstaaten weitere strafrechtliche
Gesetzgebungskompetenzen zu entziehen
wir als afd-fraktion lehnen das
selbstverständlich schon aus
grundsätzlichen Erwägungen ab
die fortlaufende Aufgabe weiterer Teile
unserer staatlichen Souveränität ist ein
schwerer Fehler und der Umstand dass
diejenigen die solche staatszersetzung
betreiben gleichzeitig mit diesem
Schlagwort auf uns zeigen die wir uns
dagegen wehren ist ein ganz schlechter
Scherz
wir sind aber nicht nur aus abstrakten
Gründen dagegen auch im konkreten bietet
der Vorgang mehr als genug Anlass zur
Ablehnung der Weg der hier gegangen
werden soll führt über die
brückenklausel in Artikel 83 des
auvertrages der hat einige Waage
gehaltene formale Voraussetzungen und um
uns bestätigen zu lassen dass es nicht
bereits daran scheitert haben wir am
Montag in EU-Ausschuss extra noch ganz
kurzfristig eine Anhörung abgehalten
hinterher war in den Hausmitteilungen
des Bundestages zu lesen die
Sachverständigen hätten allesamt
bescheinigt es sei alles ganz wunderbar
nun ja die mündlichen Äußerungen sind
das eine hilfreicher sind manchmal die
schriftlichen Ausführungen der
Sachverständigen den lassen sich gute
Gründe für erhebliche Bedenken entnehmen
denn worum geht es hier die EU macht
heutzutage ja auch in Außenpolitik und
im Zuge dessen er lässt sie Verordnungen
über Sanktionen gegen andere Staaten
aber auch gegen Einzelpersonen die
vermeintlich oder tatsächlich solche
Staaten unterstützen diese Verordnung
nun enthalten teilweise so unbestimmte
Rechtsbegriffe das sieht nach
Rechtsstaat Maßstäben eigentlich nicht
als Grundlage einer Strafbarkeit Taube
gleichwohl will die EU zukünftig auch
darüber entscheiden dass und wie
verstöße gegen diese Sanktionen
strafrechtlich verfolgt werden müssen
der Deutsche Bundestag hat die
Verantwortung dafür dass das in
Deutschland geltende Strafrecht
rechtsstaatlichen Grundsätzen entspricht
indem der Bundestag hier und heute einen
Teil seiner Gesetzgebungskompetenz für
das Strafrecht weggibt entzieht er sich
dieser Verantwortung
das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat in
seiner lissabon-entscheidung auch
dargelegt wo die äußersten Grenzen einer
Übertragung von
gesetzgebungszuständigkeiten im
Strafrecht liegen eine solche Grenze
sind die Kernaussagen des Grundgesetzes
die auf einer Verfassungsänderung
entzogen sind dazu gehört im Strafrecht
das Schuldprinzip also der Grundsatz das
nur schuldhaftes Verhalten bestraft
werden kann schuldhaft kann aber nur
menschliches Verhalten sein was nach
verbreiteter Ansicht eine Strafbarkeit
von Organisationen wie etwa Unternehmen
ausschließt nun hat die EU-Kommission
freundlicherweise bereits mitgeteilt wie
Sie Ihre zukünftige Möglichkeit das
Strafrecht in Deutschland zu bestimmen
auszunutzen gedenkt und da findet sich
dann auch das Vorhaben genau eine solche
originäre verbandsstrafbarkeit
vorzusehen es ist also bereits heute
vorhersehbar dass uns die
gesetzgeberische Tätigkeit der EU
womöglich ein Strafrecht beschert das
mit dem Grundsatz Grundgesetz nicht
vereinbar ist
das sollte eigentlich Anlass genug sein
von dem was hier heute passiert Abstand
zu nehmen da aber die ganz große
Mehrheit des Hauses
abgesehen von der AFD und partiell der
Linken sich für alle diese Dinge nicht
wirklich interessiert werden sie mit
eben dieser großen Mehrheit das
beschließen was Sie sich vorgenommen
haben das ist bedauerlich
wir können es aber bisher leider nicht
ändern vielen Dank
[Applaus]
ich muss noch einmal feststellen bevor
ich in das Wort gebe dass es bei der
Abstimmung zu TOP 11 noch eine
Enthaltung von der FDP-Fraktion gegeben
hat das möchte ich hier im Protokoll
noch mal festhalten und jetzt erhält das
Wort dr Thorsten lieb für die
FDP-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Herr Kollege Jacobi durch bloße
Wiederholung von dem was ich gestern im
Rechtsausschuss schon mal gehört habe
werden ihre Aussagen wieder juristisch
noch politisch richtiger aber dazu
später mehr seit dem 24
Februar 2022 herrscht Krieg in Europa
ein völkerrechtswidriger Angriffskrieg
gegen die Ukraine als souveränen Staat
gegen die Bürgerinnen und Bürger in der
Ukraine und ein Krieg gegen Freiheit und
Demokratie vor welcher Herausforderung
uns das als Bundesrepublik Deutschland
stellt haben wir nicht zuletzt heute mit
dem vorgestellten Abwehrschirm und
Sommer sehr ist im Sommer sehr bewusst
geworden
als Reaktion hat die Europäische Union
gegen die Russische Föderation
umfangreiche Sanktionen verhängt
gezielte Sanktionen gegen Einzelpersonen
gegen Unternehmen Beschränkungen des
Zugangs zum Kapital und Finanzmärkten
sowie umfassende wirtschaftliche
Maßnahmen und das war und ist richtig so
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Sanktionen haben erhebliche Auswirkungen
auf die Wirtschaftsleistung eine
Abmilderung oder keine Aufhebung dieser
Sanktionen kommt solange die Waffen
sprechen auf gar keinen Fall in Betracht
liebe Kolleginnen und
und ich bin der EU-Kommission dankbar
dass sie just in den letzten Tagen vor
dem Hintergrund der scheinreferenten und
der vorgesehenen Annexion nochmal
deutlich gemacht hat wir werden diesen
Weg gemeinsam gehen als Europäische
Union wir werden weitere Sanktionen dort
wo erforderlich verhängen da bleiben die
als Europäische Union gemeinsam und das
ist auch wichtig für heute festzustellen
wir bleiben an der Seite der Ukraine in
diesem Konflikt liebe Kolleginnen
damit diese Sanktionen aber Wirksamkeit
entfalten brauchen wir klare Regeln und
darum geht es in diesem Antrag klare
Regeln bei ihrer Durchsetzung deswegen
beraten wir heute abschließend den
Gesetzentwurf der Bundesregierung
aufgrund dem eben die Bundesregierung im
Rat zustimmen kann damit die Europäische
Union diesen weiteren Vorschlag
unterbreiten und dem Europäischen
Parlament vorlegen kann damit wir die
Möglichkeit bekommen auf europäischer
Ebene hier Mindestvorschriften
festzulegen und das ist der grundlegende
Irrtum Herr Kollege Jacobi es geht hier
und heute erstmal nur um die Frage ob
überhaupt die Europäische Kommission
Vorschläge machen kann wie diese konkret
ausgestaltet sind wie diese aussehen das
werden wir selbstverständlich und dass
unser Recht als Deutscher Bundestag im
Einzelnen beraten ob das zu deutschen
Strafrecht passt das ist unsere Aufgabe
und es geht nicht darum dass heute schon
zu bewerten weil die Vorschläge noch
überhaupt nicht vorliegen
was aber
aber doch nicht als rechtsdokument was
an den Text den wir beraten technisch
klingt ist in zweierlei Hinsicht finde
ich noch mal bemerkenswert erstens und
bereits damit erweisen sich alle
Vorwürfe als obsolet wir beraten das
heute und stimmen darüber ab im
Deutschen Bundestag in den breitesten
partizipationsverfahren aller Parlamente
in der Europäischen Union wer dann noch
sagen möchte das sei irgendwie
undemokratisch er weiß ich nicht der
braucht vielleicht mal ein
staatsrechtlichen nachhilfekurs
Kolleginnen
zweitens leisten wir mit der Zustimmung
für die ich hier noch mal ausdrücklich
werbe ein ganz wichtigen Beitrag dass
wir als Europäische Union gemeinsam
stehen und einen wichtigen Beitrag zur
effektiven Durchsetzung dieser
Sanktionen Leistens schon angesprochen
worden ist in der Tat erstaunlich wie
unterschiedlich das ist im Augenblick
wir brauchen aber diese Geschlossenheit
als Europäische Union genau in diesem
Zeiten wenn wir dem heute zustimmen hat
der Rat nun die Möglichkeit rechtssicher
uns Vorschläge zu machen in den
parlamentarischen Prozess einzubringen
gerade um und ich glaube das ist
dringend notwendig um endlich
Möglichkeiten zu schaffen in diese
Vermögen auch einzugreifen ein
Anbetracht des fortdauernden Krieges und
des aufholbedarfs oder des
reparaturbedarfs in der Ukraine ist das
auch dringend dringend notwendig was das
Amt wir als Deutscher Bundestag wir
kommen unsere integrationsverantwortung
nach wie genügen dieser
integrationsverantwortung wenn wir heute
diesem Gesetzentwurf zustimmen diesen
Weg eröffnen für die Europäische
Kommission dann freuen wir uns auf die
konkreten Vorschläge der Europäischen
Kommission da werden wir hier gemeinsam
in deutschen Bundestag und ihnen
Ausschüssen beraten wie das dann konkret
ausgestalten wird um es nochmal deutlich
zu machen wir leisten mit dem Vorschlag
ein entscheidenden Beitrag zur
effektiven Durchsetzung der Sanktionen
deswegen werden wir als FDP-Fraktion
heute zustimmen alles andere wird sich
weisen vielen herzlichen Dank
können nicht Thorsten lieb an natürlich
ist der Krieg Russland gegen die Ukraine
im nächsten Redner hier bedeuten wenn es
um die Sanktionen geht aber auch in
Zukunft könnte das natürlich eine Rolle
spielen wie die verschiedenen
Mitgliedstaaten da sich verhalten
hier wurde kurz zum Geburtstag
gratuliert André hunko
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin meine Damen
und Herren worum geht es in dieser
Debatte es geht darum dass auf EU-Ebene
ein neuer Straftatbestand geschaffen
werden soll
sanktionsverstoß der in die Bereiche der
Kriminalität hinzugefügt werden soll in
einem ersten Schritt um die
grundlagenverträge entsprechend zu
ändern also sanktionsverstoß wird gleich
behandelt dann von der EU wie
Terrorismus wie Menschenhandel und dabei
geht es nicht nur um die aktuellen
russland-sanktionen da kann man ja auch
unterschiedlicher Meinungen zu sein
sonst geht um alle
Sanktionsregime wir haben jetzt schon
über 40
eu-sanktionsregime da geht es um
Sanktionen die sowohl Oligarchen
betreffen
individuelle Übeltäter betreffen aber
eben auch um umfangreiche
Wirtschaftssanktionen die die
Bevölkerung treffen und ich sage ganz
klar die Linke lehnt Sanktionen die die
Bevölkerung betreffen ab egal ob in
Russland oder hierzulande
wir sehen diese Entwicklung
zunehmende
unilateraler Sanktionen wir reden ja
nicht über UN-Sanktionen wir reden nicht
über Urteile von internationalen
Gerichten das ist eine ganz andere
Kategorie wir reden über unilaterale
Sanktionen wir nehmen diese Entwicklung
sehen diese Entwicklung sehr kritisch
ich habe schon von für über 40
eu-sanktionsregime gesprochen in den USA
wächst das auch sehr stark und ich kann
auch sagen in der UN in den Vereinten
Nationen wird diese Entwicklung auch
sehr kritisch gesehen und auch der
Generalsekretär äußert sich immer wieder
kritisch zu solchen sanktionsregimen
deshalb werden wir diesen Antrag
ablehnen genauso wie das auch unsere
Fraktion geschlossen im Europaparlament
gemacht hat
zusätzlich zu diesen
zugegebenermaßen komplexen Vorgang wird
jetzt ganz kurzfristig in diesen
Gesetzentwurf noch eine Änderung zum
Infektionsschutzgesetz angeflanscht ich
halte das für einen diese sogenannte
omnibusverfahren ich halte das für einen
völlig intransparenten Vorgang wo ein
ganz sachfremdes Thema angeflanscht wird
das lehnen wir natürlich auch ab auch
das wäre schon ein Grund diese dieses
Gesetzesvorhaben abzulehnen ich finde
solche Sachen müssen getrennt diskutiert
werden damit man sich da eine Meinung
bilden kann zusammengefasst
diese neue Ermächtigung sozusagen für
die EU
sanktionsverstöße wie Terrorismus oder
Menschenhandel behandeln zu können in
Zukunft ist völlig unabhängig auch jetzt
noch mal vom vom Ukraine Krieg und der
Situation mit Russland auch mit Blick
auf künftige
mögliche Sanktionsregime kritisch zu
sehen vor allen Dingen dann wenn es
Wirtschaftssanktionen sind deswegen
werden wir diesen Gesetzentwurf ablehnen
vielen Dank
andere hunko stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzender und Europa
politischer Sprecher seiner Fraktion hat
hier schon das Abstimmungsverhalten der
Linken angekündigt Sebastian Fiedler
jetzt für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren ich möchte versuchen
den vielen richtigen Ausführungen warum
das jetzt wichtig ist dass wir das
machen warum das sehr demokratisch
legitimiert ist noch ein paar Aspekte
die ein bisschen auch mit meiner
beruflichen Herkunft zu tun haben
hinzufügen weil es ja darum geht um die
grundsätzliche Frage warum auch andere
kriminalitätsbereiche in diesem Artikel
83 drinstehen und warum wir hier etwas
hinzufügen sollten und will das
versuchen in Verbindung zu setzen zu ein
paar anderen Themen die insbesondere
auch von den deutschen und europäischen
rechtsauslegern immer so ins Feld
geführt werden und dazu zwei Aspekte die
noch nicht genannt worden sind man muss
glaube ich auch noch erläutern das ist
ganz interessant ist doch einmal noch
nachzulesen aus welchen Gründen sich
Personen oder Entitäten das heißt also
Unternehmen auf diesen Listen befinden
das kann man sehr transparent nachlesen
da stehen nämlich Begründungen drin auf
welche Weise um jetzt bei Russland zu
bleiben das System Putin durch diese
Personen unter oder Unternehmen
unterstützt wird und das ist im übrigen
auch justiziabel wer also da nicht mit
einverstanden ist geht zum Europäischen
Gerichtshof und hier ist der
Rechtsschutz eröffnet das heißt wir
reden über ein ganz rechtssicheres und
demokratisch legitimiertes Verfahren
übrigens einstimmig beschlossen im
außenrat
das gehört glaube ich noch hinzu und
dann will ich das Einfügen in ein
Themenfeld was wir viel zu selten
diskutieren und deren Bedeutung wird zu
selten herausreden Europa die
Europäische Union ist ein Raum der
Freiheit der Sicherheit und des Rechts
und das kommt in diesem Artikel
außerordentlich gut zum Ausdruck und ich
will die ganzen Bereiche die
exemplarisch angesprochen worden sind
aus dem Artikel 83 doch durch die aus
noch mal eben kurz sagen Terrorismus
Menschenhandel sexuelle Ausbeutung von
Frauen und Kindern Drogenhandel
illegaler Waffenhandel Geldwäsche
Korruption Fälschung von Zahlungsmittel
Computerkriminalität und organisierte
Kriminalität und dazu fügen wir jetzt
die sanktionsverstöße noch zusätzlich
ein warum ist das wichtig weil uns die
Rechtsaußen das muss man noch erzählen
was die AFD hier vergisst zu sagen sie
hat ja Parteitagsbeschlüsse sie will
Austreten aus der Europäischen Union
Deutschland soll raus sie will hat in
andere Programme reingeschrieben gut
dass sie noch mal klatschen und ich
versuche das in andere Kontexte zu
setzen sie wollen die Mittel von
sowohl kürzen und von euroneust Stürzen
das sind nämlich die Themen die dahinter
stecken da steckt die europäische
Sicherheitsarchitektur dahinter und das
macht es gerade so paradox also ich habe
wirklich viele Delegationen mit mit
Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus den
Sicherheitsbehörden mit Staatsanwältin
und Staatsanwälten geführt innerhalb der
Europäischen Union wir haben die
Institutionen besucht wir waren bei
Europe kein einziger und keine einzige
käme auf die
Abo sagen wir hätten eine bessere
Situation bei der internationalen
Kriminalitätsbekämpfung wenn wir
entweder Austreten aus der Europäischen
Union oder sagen wir schaffen Europol
oder Eurojust ab dass eine groteske
Argumentation der Nationalisten in einer
Europäischen Union
und deswegen müssen wir hier jede
Gelegenheit nutzen und all denjenigen
die zugucken die bei den
Sicherheitsbehörden Arbeiten zu sagen
warum die Rechtsausleger die in den
Parlamenten sitzen ein Sicherheitsrisiko
sind sie wollen sozusagen den
wichtigsten Institutionen bei der
Bekämpfung der schwerwiegendsten
kriminalitätsfelder den Stecker ziehen
sie wollen Europol die Mittel kürzen Sie
wollen da wo die Staatsanwältin und
Staatsanwälte in Europa zusammen
kooperieren die mittelkürzen und sie
sind gegen eine europäische
Staatsanwaltschaft die wir dazu
eingeführt haben um die wichtigsten
kriminalitätsfelder gemeinsam ohne an
rechtshilfegrenzen zu stehen tatsächlich
zu bekämpfen die Idee der europäischen
Rechtsausleger ist die Pickelhaube am
Schengen Grenzbaum das ist ihre Idee sie
wollen mit Uniform an den Binnengrenzen
stehen und da die internationale
Computerkriminalität die internationale
organisierte Kriminalität bekämpfen das
ist ihr Konzept und das sagen sie all
ihren Gruppen bei den
Sicherheitsbehörden wenn sie wieder
Wahlkampf machen und mit Beiträgen zur
klaren Kriminalität versuchen das Hohe
Haus hier zu beglücken das hat
unmittelbar nämlich mit diesen
Themenfeld zu tun was wir hier
besprechen weil wir natürlich sagen wir
wollen nicht Kriegspartei werden
stattdessen wollen wir Sanktionen
gemeinsam mit den europäischen
Partnerinnen und Partnern beschließen
und wer dagegen verstößt der muss
natürlich sich mit der Mitteln des
Strafrechts verfolgen und wir schaffen
nicht mehr als den Rahmen über den
anschließend im europäischen Kontext und
dann anschließend auch hier das Hohe
Haus natürlich noch mal in der Folge
demokratisch abstimmt vorher passiert
hier gar nichts da können Sie noch so
viel im Rechtsausschuss erzählen und
fabulieren oder hier das noch mal wieder
bringen genauso ist es dass haben meine
Kolleginnen und Kollegen schon
wiedergegeben also mehr Europa auch in
der Verbrechensbekämpfung das ist das
was hier drin steckt und da sind wir
alle für
Sebastian Fiedler war das und damit
kommen wir zum letzten Redner bevor die
Abgeordneten hier über diesen
Gesetzentwurf der Bundesregierung
abstimmen das ist Alexander Radfahren
von der Unionsfraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
[Musik]
Ursache
anlass dieser Gesetzgebung auf
europäischer Ebene dieser Initiative ist
wie können wir die Sanktionen die
notwendigen Sanktionen Europas gegen
Russland in Europa durchsetzen
da lassen Sie mich mal ich knüpf ein
wenig beim Kollegen Fiedler an
aber ich habe den Fokus jetzt mal drauf
wie sieht es denn in der Praxis aus und
da möchte ich mal anfangen am 22 April
diesen Jahres
da war ihr Parteivorsitzender in meinem
Wahlkreis bei mir in der Heimat am
Tegernsee er war ein Gmund hat dort ein
Interview gegeben hat über den See rüber
geschaut nach Rottach-Egern schätze ich
und hatte dort von Herrn usmanov die
Villa im Blick und hat dort dann kann
ihr jeder nachschauen gesagt also ihr
seid dafür dass die Sanktionen
durchgesetzt wird und er will nicht nur
einfrieren sondern er will auch das
ganze Vermögen einziehen um entsprechend
das Vermögen herzuziehen um in der
Ukraine es aufzubauen
und seitdem beschäftige ich mich
natürlich auch sehr stark wie setzen wir
eigentlich das ganze was vorhanden ist
um sie sind ja jemand der aus dem Berit
kommt sich auch regelmäßig öffentlich
äußert und da wurden erst Arbeitsgruppen
gebildet hier in Deutschland dann kam
das erste sanktionsdurchsetzungsgesetz
weil natürlich die Abläufe im föderalen
Staat sehr schwierig sind
aber dieses erste
sanktionsdurchsetzungsgesetz wurde ja
schon so angekündigt dass man sagt wir
wissen ein zweites muss folgen
formuliere sehr freundlich
und gleichzeitig hatten wir jetzt die
Tage bei mir eine Razzia es ging durch
die Medien auch am Tegernsee aber
generell
um hier waren also Hundertschaften sind
ins Haus rein haben Durchsuchungen
gemacht haben die Sachen wo notwendiges
festgestellt
Basis dafür war nach dem Medienberichten
nicht das auktionsrecht sondern es war
der Steuerrecht es ist natürlich mein
Mitleid mit den Herrn usman noch nur
bedingt weil er sich mit dem Steuerrecht
in Deutschland anliegt und im
Steuerstrafrecht der hat schon was zu
beißen und das Außenwirtschaftsgesetz
aber letztendlich ist es ein Kunstgriff
und darum ist es gut so und jetzt komme
ich zu dem europäischen Recht dass wir
auf europäischer Ebene jetzt eine
entsprechende Ermächtigung machen dass
wir entsprechenden Straftatbestand
erweitern können es geht wie sie zu
Recht gesagt haben um ein Mindestmaß
hier und um die Erweiterung
grenzüberschreitender sachverhältnis
geht ja darum wo es national nicht außer
sondern international und europäisch sie
haben sich jetzt sehr stark an der AFD
abgearbeitet das was ich von Herrn
Jacobi in letzter Zeit höre bringt halt
in mir die Erwartungen zum Vorschein die
AFD möchte die internationale
Kriminalität am liebsten mit den Prag
den polizeiaufgabengesetz der
Bundesländer bekämpfen das wäre Ansatz
der internationalen Kriminalität zu
antworten das ist halt schon sehr sehr
provinziell wie sie das Thema und das
auch an die Herrschaften hier in
keinster Weise gerecht werden wie sie
die Herausforderung entsprechend
begegnen wollen und die EU-Kommission
hat jetzt dann entsprechend die
Möglichkeit der Regelung zu lassen in
einem zweistufen-system und eins möchte
ich hier schon noch betonen die
Strafrecht Thematik ist notwendig auf
europäischer Ebene aber dann und das
sagen auch unsere Innenpolitiker wollen
wir eben nicht nur einfrieren und die
Kommission will ja nicht nur free
sondern sie will auch sie ist sie will
es auch entsprechend einziehen und darum
ist hier entsprechend notwendig dass wir
eine nationale Gesetzgebung haben dass
die nationale Politik hier dem Vorgaben
macht um es entsprechend einzusetzen
meine Damen und Herren das ist das was
wir erwarten dass nach dem europäischen
nach dem Hoffen auf europäischer Ebene
und da blicke ich insbesondere die
beiden Fraktionen an weil wir wissen auf
europäischer Ebene bei diesem
Gesetzgebung des Einziehens vom Vermögen
gibt es eine Fraktion die den
Bundesjustizminister stellt die sich da
sehr sehr schwer tut sowohl auf
europäischer Ebene dieses entsprechend
zu unterstützen als auch dann auf
nationale Ebene der Gesetzesentwurf der
gerade vorliegt beim zweiten
sanktionsdurchsetzungsgesetz beinhaltet
dazu eben noch nichts und darum mein
Appell an die anderen beiden der
Ampelkoalition setzen Sie sich hier mal
gegen die Freien Demokraten durch helfen
sie uns dass diese
Sanktionsmöglichkeiten und diese
Möglichkeiten dieser Bundesstaat hier
hat nicht nur in einem ersten Schritt
sind sondern geben Sie ihm Szene dass er
dann auch entsprechend umgesetzt werden
das wäre mein Appell an sie besten Dank
[Applaus]
einen schönen guten Abend liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von meiner
Seite auf dem BesucherInnen Besuchen auf
der Tribüne mit dem letzten Redner für
diese Debatte schließe ich die
Aussprache und wir kommen zur Abstimmung
über den von der Bundesregierung
eingebrachten Gesetzentwurf zum Entwurf
eines Beschlusses über die Feststellung
des Verstoßes gegen restriktive
Maßnahmen der Union als einen die
Kriterien nach Artikel 83 Absatz 1 des
Vertrages über die Arbeitsweise der
Europäischen Union erfüllenden
kriminalitätsbereich der Ausschuss für
die Angelegenheiten
wir sind jetzt gerade in der Abstimmung
nee jetzt erstmal
wir sind jetzt in der Abstimmung
kleinen Moment
hier gibt es ein bisschen Unstimmigkeit
wir konnten nicht ganz hören was Stefan
Brandner von der AFD sich wünscht aber
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin Yvonne mag was
berät sich nun kurz
wir sind uns hier oben nicht einig
dass
wir sehen uns hier oben nicht einig
knapp über 40
also wir hören mal zu weil leider Stefan
Brandner sein Mikrofon nicht an hatte es
könnte sein dass er die
Beschlussfähigkeit des Parlaments
anzweifelt
und das würde bedeuten
dass wir hier zählen müssen wer alles
vor Ort ist
[Musik]
also wir sehen uns hier im Saal
sozusagen nicht einig nicht im soll
eigentlich sondern hier oben nicht einig
von daher
müssen wir wohl
in einen hammelsprung einsteigen
ich bitte Sie
genau es ist faktisch die
Beschlussfähigkeit in Verbindung mit der
Abstimmung
durch Zählen der Stimmen festzustellen
das bedeutet hammelsprung und das
bedeutet dass Sie jetzt bitte den Saal
verlassen
so das
ist ja mittlerweile eigentlich schon in
diesem Bundestag eine doch häufiger
vorkommende Übung die afd-fraktion hat
er hier bezweifelt das genügend
Abgeordnete im Saal sind um hier diese
Abstimmung durchzuführen und das muss
nun also geprüft werden wie prüft man
das alle Abgeordneten verlassen jetzt
hier den Saal und dann werden sie
einzeln eintreten und dabei von den
saaldienerinnen und Saal Dienern gezählt
und dann wissen wir ob genügend
Abgeordnete
hier der Sitzung beiwohnen dass das
Parlament beschlussfähig ist und sie
sehen jetzt hier mehrere
Menschen telefonieren das hat natürlich
damit zu tun dass besonders die
parlamentarischen geschäftsordner nun
versuchen alle Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die sich hier in der Reichweite des
Parlaments befinden also die
Abgeordneten die hier herbeizuzitieren
denn wenn das Parlament nicht
beschlussfähig ist dann können wir
natürlich hier in der Sitzung nicht
weitermachen von daher versuchen jetzt
hier die verschiedenen
Fraktions Mitglieder bzw die
Parlamentarischen Geschäftsführer dort
ihre Kolleginnen und Kollegen noch mal
herbeizutelefonieren deswegen dauert das
auch immer relativ lange bis sich die
Abgeordneten hier aus dem Saal bewegen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
möchte noch mal für alle auch für die
parlamentarische Geschäftsführer zur
Kenntnis geben dass wir jetzt die
Beschlussfähigkeit verbinden mit der
Abstimmung über den Gesetzentwurf so
dass sie das auch entsprechend in ihrer
Fraktionen kommunizieren können
also Yvonne mag was hat hier auch noch
mal dann dazu aufgerufen den Saal zu
verlassen das dauert wie gesagt noch mal
ein bisschen länger übrigens das Wort
hammelsprung
wirkt natürlich sehr umgangssprachlich
ist auch tatsächlich nicht in der
Geschäftsordnung des Parlaments zu
finden wird aber seit langem verwendet
die erste das erste Mal dass dieser
Begriff aufgetaucht ist war
1879 und auch schon
früher ein geflügeltes Wort das hatte
noch damit zu tun dass die Türen wenn es
um eine Abstimmung ging da gab es ja
drei Türen gibt es immer noch drei Türen
durch die die Abgeordneten durchgehen
können um einen
abstimmungszeichen zu geben also ja nein
oder Enthaltung steht über den und damit
können dann die Abgeordneten mit ihren
Füßen abstimmen und über der nein Tür
gab es dort früher im alten
Reichstagsgebäude ein Bild der
Märchengestalt Rübezahl und über der
jahrtür gab es ein Bild des blinden
Zyklopen Polyphem also aus der Odysseus
sage sie erinnern sich bestimmt der den
Widdern über den Rücken streicht und
damals hatte sich Odysseus und seine
Gefährten an den Bäuchen der Widder
unten ran
geklammert damit der
Zyklop sie eben nicht ertasten kann und
da wird immer wieder drauf verwiesen
dass eben dieses Bild nun hier auf die
Abgeordneten auch übertragen wird und
dann dieser doch recht humoristische
Name hammelsprung für einfach eine
Abstimmung benutzt wird
sie sehen es gibt noch viele Abgeordnete
die doch recht langsam hier sich nur aus
dem Saal bewegen und weil
wir natürlich die Zeit nutzen wollen um
Ihnen noch mehr inhaltliches hier zu
zeigen möchten wir Ihnen gerne noch
einmal einen Ausschnitt aus der
aktuellen Stunde zeigen heute Nachmittag
gab es ja eine Aktuelle Stunde auf
Verlangen der Fraktion SPD Bündnis 90
die Gründe und FDP zu den Protesten im
Iran anlass ist der Tod von Massa Amini
die ja in Polizei Gewahrsam gekommen ist
weil sie das Kopftuch nach an weil sie
das Kopftuch nicht so getragen hat wie
es die Sittenpolizei für angemessen
findet im Iran gibt es ja sehr strikte
Kleidervorschriften am 13 September
wurde sie festgenommen ist dann auf der
Polizeiwache zusammengebrochen und starb
drei Tage später im Krankenhaus es ist
nicht klar woran sie gestorben ist
aber seitdem gibt es Unruhen im Iran
Menschen gehen auf die Straße und
natürlich wollten hier auch die
Abgeordneten darüber diskutieren und
auch darüber diskutieren wie sich
Deutschland verhält und da möchten wir
Ihnen noch mal einen außenschnitt zeigen
aus dieser Debatte der startet mit
unserer bundesaußenministerin Annalena
baerbock
aus dieser puren Gewalt des iranischen
Systems spricht pure Furcht
der nichts
der nichts fürchten jene die mit
betäubener Gewalt regieren mehr als das
Frauen gemeinsam auf die Straße gehen
und ihre Stimme erheben und diese Stimme
lässt sich nicht einfach niederknüppeln
sie lässt sich auch nicht abschalten
indem man dem Zugang zum Internet kappt
nein diese Stimme schallt laut und weit
über Iran hinaus ich habe daher den
Botschafter eingestellt und wir haben am
Montag für die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland dem Menschenrechtsrat in
Genf ganz deutlich klargestellt die
iranischen Behörden müssen ihr brutales
Vorgehen gegen die Demonstranten und
Demonstranten unverzüglich einstellen
der vor der Tod von Gina masamini und
der vielen weiteren Menschen die bei den
Demonstrationen getötet wurden gehört
dringend aufgeklärt
und im Kreis der EU-Staaten im Kreis der
EU-Staaten tue ich gerade alles dafür
dass wir Sanktionen auf den Weg bringen
können gerade jetzt ja gerade auch jetzt
wo wir weiter über das jcpoa Verhandeln
Sanktionen gegen diejenigen in Iran auf
dem Weg zu bringen die ohne Rücksicht
Frauen im Namen der Religion zu Tode
prügeln
Demonstranten erschießen ich möchte
meinen Beitrag dazu nutzen mich nicht
mit begriffen sondern mit der Politik
der Außenministerin seit der Ermordung
von Frau Massa Amini zu beschäftigen ich
möchte mich mit den Taten mit den
Realitäten in den vergangenen zwei
Wochen beschäftigen und zu diesen
Realitäten haben sie wenig gesagt heute
in ihrer Rede zu ihrer Politik diese
betreiben sehr geehrte Frau
Außenministerin darum möchte ich das tun
zu den Tatsachen ihrer Politik zählt
dass sie tagelang nach der Ermordung
nichts gesagt haben ein schütteln Sie
nicht mit dem Kopf sie haben tagelang
nichts gesagt es ist bislang nichts
gefolgt sie sind bei den Sanktionen
immer noch im prüfstadium keine
Konsequenzen und in den und und in den
Sprache das Minimum des notwendigen was
man sagen muss als demokratische
Politikerin kein bisschen mehr aber es
gibt dafür einen Grund und den müssen
sie auch benennen dann müssen Sie auch
transparent im Parlament sein der Grund
ist das nuklearabkommen das sogenannte
jcpa die Politik der Bundesregierung ist
dass um dieses Ziel nicht zu gefährden
es hängt sowieso in der Schwebe es ist
fast schon tot aber es ist noch nicht
wirklich tot und um das nuklearabkommen
nicht zu gefährden haben Sie sich dazu
entschieden gegenüber dem Regime
zurückhaltend zu sein sie haben Angst
wenn wir voll auf der Seite der Frauen
stehen dann stehen wir voll gegen das
Regime und diese Kritik wollen sie nicht
machen um das andere Ziel nicht zu
gefährden das ist ihre Politik
sie haben Angst vor meinem Haar sie
haben Angst vor meiner Stimme sie haben
Angst vor meinem Körper ich als Frau
kann ein ganzes Regime verängstigen
das ist ein Zitat der iranischen
Journalistin Marie Aline
jetzt gerade in diesen Tagen gehen im
Iran tausende Menschen auf die Straße
sie gehen für ihre Rechte für ihre
Freiheit und für ihre Selbstbestimmung
auf die Straße und allen voran die
Frauen die auf offener Straße ihre
Schleier verbrennen für uns
unvorstellbar riskieren Sie dabei Leib
und Leben und eines muss uns allen klar
sein hier geht es nicht um den Hintern
und ob er falsch saß hier geht es auch
nicht um Religion hier geht es um
Kontrolle über die Körper über die
Selbstbestimmung und über die Freiheit
von Frauen und eigentlich geht es um die
Freiheit im Iran insgesamt
dann nicht nur die Frauen wünschen sich
Freiheit sondern natürlich auch Männer
und sie haben eines gemeinsam sie wählen
sich gegen die Unterdrückung
die grüne Regierungspartei sollte
angesichts der aktuellen protestet den
Mund nicht voll nehmen es war der
erzgrüne Joschka Fischer der in der
linksradikalen Zeitschrift
pflasterstrand die Islamische Revolution
mit den Worten pries sie richte sich
gegen das Eindringen des kommunistischen
des konsumistischen das Einbringen das
konsumistischen Atheismus der westlichen
Industriegesellschaften derselbe Joschka
Fischer der als Außenminister die noch
immer in den Köpfen der Linken dümpele
Schnapsidee eines unwürdigen
atomabkommens mit diesem Staat
vorangetrieben hat und es war die
damalige grüne Vorsitzende Claudia Roth
eine selbst ernannte Feministin die den
iranischen Botschafter mit High Five
begrüßt hat nämlich es trifft auf die
SPD zu ihr Bundespräsident Steinmeier
verschickte im Namen seiner Landsleute
Glückwunsch Telegramme anlässlich des
Jahrestags der islamischen Revolution
in Artikel 3 der iranischen Verfassung
wird eine Außenpolitik auf der Grundlage
der islamischen Maßstäbe vorgeschrieben
und wie diese Werte gebundene
Außenpolitik aussieht das wissen wir zur
Genüge die Islamische Republik war
niemals auch nicht unter den
vermeintlich gemäßigten Reformen um
rohani eine
stabilitätsgarant für die Region sie war
und ist im Gegenteil der wichtigste
Finanzier von Tod und Terror im Nahen
Osten
wir hatten gestern eine wunderbare
Demonstration gehabt am Brandenburger
Tor und ich kann nur hier wiederholen
was ich auch dort gesagt habe
Solidarität und warme Worte reichen
nicht mehr aus
der Tod der Tod der 22-jährigen Massa
armini hat uns auf tragische Weise vor
Augen geführt dass sie eine fundamental
andere Iran-Politik brauchen meine Damen
und Herren
während wir wären wir gestern hier im
Deutschen Bundestag im Plenum diskutiert
haben haben iranische Drohnen die
Drohnen der Revolutionswächter zivile
Ziele in der autonomen Region Kurdistans
Irak angegriffen europa braucht eine
neue Iran Strategie wir können nicht
ständig wir können nicht ständig nur
über ein atomabkommen reden während
gleichzeitig im Iran seit vielen vielen
Jahren eklatante
Menschenrechtsverletzungen stattfinden
meine Damen und Herren viel zu lange ist
die Europäische Union mit dem Iran einen
naiven Kuschelkurs Gefahren viel zu
lange wurde zu eklatanten
Menschenrechtsverletzungen immer und
immer wieder geschwiegen mit dieser
beschämende Haltung muss ein für alle
mal ein Ende haben meine Damen und
Herren
ich finde es gut dass in Deutschland und
in anderen Ländern viele Menschen auf
die Straße gehen um sich mit den mutigen
Frauen im Iran zu solidarisieren als
Bundestagsabgeordnete mit kurdischer
Migrationsgeschichte weiß sich wie
wichtig Solidarität in solchen Zeiten
sind die deutsche Realpolitik führt
unter der Ampelkoalition weiterhin einen
Kuschelkurs gegenüber Autokratien
gegenüber dem mulla-regime das Frauen
unterdrückt gegen nur Erdogan der
koordinnen mit chemischen Waffen
bekämpft gegenüber den Saudis die in
jenen jahrelang Zivilisten bombardiert
haben Erdogan möchte man als NATO
Verbündeten nicht verlieren außerdem
soll er ja die Flüchtlinge aus Europa
fernhalten
Saudi-Arabien ist wichtiger
Energielieferant und bei dem mularisimi
im Iran fürchtet man eine Gefährdung der
Neuauflage des atomabkommens im Großen
und Ganzen geht das hier wieder um
Profite und geostrategische Interessen
aber so darf es nicht weitergehen
die mutigen Frauen im Iran brauchen
unsere Solidarität Frau berborg hat nach
ihrem amttritt eine feministische
hauspolitik angekündigt auch wenn sie
von Kriegsmüdigkeit inzwischen sprechen
in ihrer Außenpolitik wer wäre es jetzt
zeigt dass sie unter Beweis stellen wie
sie es auch wirklich mit den Feminismus
meinen handeln sie endlich
soweit also hier unser Ausschnitt aus
der aktuellen Stunde zu den Protesten in
Iran dort haben sich natürlich auch
vorher schon einige Politikerinnen und
Politiker zu geäußert wie Deutschland
sich da verhalten kann um entweder die
Zerschlagung dieser Proteste zu
verurteilen oder auch die
Protestierenden zu unterstützen auch in
Deutschland gibt es ja mehrere Proteste
schon um die Solidarität mit dem
Protestierenden im Iran auszudrücken und
sie sehen die offenen Türen zum
Plenarsaal im Deutschen Bundestag denn
die Abgeordneten führen gerade einen
hammelsprung durch hintergrund ist dass
die afd-fraktion die Beschlussfähigkeit
des Parlaments angezweifelt hat also ob
genügend Abgeordnete
hier im Saal sind um hier über einen
Gesetzentwurf abzustimmen
736 Mitglieder hatte Deutsche Bundestag
und das bedeutet um beschlussfähig zu
sein muss mehr als die Hälfte der
Mitglieder des Bundestags anwesend sein
also
das Präsidium war sich nicht einig ob
dieser Anzahl wirklich gerade vorhanden
ist und dann hilft es nichts müssen alle
Abgeordneten den Plenarsaal verlassen
und kommen jetzt nach und nach wieder
rein werden dabei gezählt an jeder Tür
stehen zwei Saal Diener bzw Saal
Dienerinnen und zählen und sagen dann
der
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin Yvonne marquas
Bescheid ob das Plenum hier also
fortgeführt werden kann und ob die
Abgeordneten über einen Gesetzentwurf
mit der Bundesregierung abstimmen können
ich kann noch mal sagen worum es geht es
geht nämlich um ein sehr wichtiges Thema
in der heutigen Zeit wie nämlich die EU
die
sanktionsdurchsetzung vereinheitlichen
kann das ist gerade in den Zeiten in
denen wir jetzt sind von großer Relevanz
wo nämlich die EU doch Sanktionen
gegenüber Personen Unternehmen
[Musik]
verabschiedet hat die den russlandkrieg
gegen die Ukraine unterstützen und
deswegen möchte die Europäische Union
das noch weiter vereinheitlichen wieder
die Mitgliedstaaten reagieren und um das
auch abzustimmen und muss ein deutscher
Vertreter im Rat der Europäischen Union
dieser
Harmonisierung zustimmen und deswegen
gibt es hier einen Gesetzentwurf und als
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin diesen
Gesetzentwurf hier zur Abstimmung
bringen wollte hat Stefan Brandner von
der afd-fraktion eben die
Beschlussfähigkeit des Parlaments
angezweifelt
so lange wie die Abgeordneten sich hier
wieder einfinden wollen wir die Zeit
nutzen um im Thema zu bleiben und um uns
das Thema noch einmal näher zu bringen
deswegen haben wir Ihnen noch einmal ein
paar Ausschnitte aus der Debatte zur
Harmonisierung der sanktionsdurchsetzung
in der EU zusammengestellt
als dezidierter nicht-tourist spreche
ich hier bei diesem Thema als
überzeugter Europäer und nicht nur als
Mitglied des Ausschusses für europäische
Angelegenheiten als ein überzeugter
Europäer der auch mit Hilfe der
trockenen Rechtsprechung hofft die
Zukunft auf unserem Kontinent und
darüber hinaus friedlich und
prosperierend gestalten zu können
prosperierend ist hier allerdings nicht
in einem herkömmlichen vereinfachten
Sinne mit Wirtschaftswachstum zu
verwechseln sondern weit darüber hinaus
als am blühendes gedeihen einer
vielfältigen Zivilgesellschaft zu
verstehen
die schon das Sams in den Büchern von
Paul Maar bei dem Gebrauch von
Wunschpunkten einforderte genauestens
genau zu wünschen so ist das auch auf
dem Feld der Rechtsprechung wichtig und
wesentlich genau zu sein
nachzujustieren wenn sich Probleme bei
der Durchsetzung des gültigen rechtes
zeigen
die Europäische Kommission möchte
erreichen dass sie Verletzungen von
EU-Sanktionen zu Straftaten erklärt
werden um so die Verfolgung effektiver
zu gestalten
wir als Bundestag müssen dem zuvor
zustimmen das Verstöße gegen die von der
EU verhängten Sanktionen in den
kriminalitätsbereich übernommen werden
können
so einfach so gut und darum geht es hier
nicht unwesentlich ist vielleicht der
Hinweis dass Deutschland das letzte
europäische Land ist das hier noch auf
nationaler Ebene zustimmen muss
dies liegt diesmal nicht am langsamen
Internet sondern daran dass wir eines
der wenigen Parlamente sind überhaupt
damit befasst werden ein Zeichen unserer
starken parlamentarischen Demokratie
vor dem Hintergrund des Krieges den
Russland gegen die Ukraine führt ist
diese rechtliche Schwachstelle beim
Sanktionen noch einmal deutlich
hervorgetreten verbunden mit dem Problem
dass eine Harmonisierung des Strafmaßes
in den Mitgliedstaaten von Nöten ist
denn wenn dieses das Strafmaß in den
unterschiedlichen europäischen Ländern
von einigen tausend bis zu mehreren
hunderttausend Euro variiert lässt das
nicht nur Fachleute wie Laien staunen
sondern Zeug nicht gerade von einer gut
aufgestellten einheitlichen
Geschlossenheit
Sanktionen zu verhängen ist das eine sie
aber auch nachhaltig und effektiv
durchsetzen zu können das andere hier
nachzubessern ist notwendig und dringend
geboten
die expert:innen Anhörung im Ausschuss
hat das einhellig und deutlich
unterstrichen nicht ohne auf die
Schwierigkeiten im Detail nämlich die
Präzisierung zu verweisen aber diese ist
auch erst der zweite Schritt auf
europäischer Ebene den wir heute durch
unsere Beschluss erst ermöglichen
es geht um eine vernünftige
nachvollziehbare Regulierung jetzt vor
allem rechtlich abgesichert werden muss
damit die Europäische Union in diesem
Punkt international handlungsfähig und
verlässlich bleiben kann
diese Regelung um es knapp zu sagen ist
einfach notwendig und wichtig und nur
der Teufel wird sicherlich noch im
Detail stecken wo zum Beispiel noch die
einzelnen Tatbestände rechtssicher und
wir erinnern uns genauestens genauso
definiert werden müssen
hier seien nur alle in diesem Haus
beruhigt denn diese Ausformulierung wird
erneut hier im Parlament verhandelt und
besprochen und dann erst auf dem
rechtsgültigen Weg gebracht
eingangs ließ sich schon darauf hin dass
ich an überzeugter Europäer bin ein
Umstand auf den hinzuweisen in diesen
Tagen vielleicht wieder notwendiger wird
als alle hier oder fast alle hier
gedacht und gehofft hatten
eine starke Gemeinschaft verträgt
durchaus Unruhen Aggression von innen
und außen kann darauf reagieren damit
diskursiv umgehen und nicht nur in der
Europäischen Union hilft Kritik häufig
einfach um besser zu werden so wie
Demokratie nie ein festgefügter
Endzustand ist sondern ein Prozess einen
immerwährendes aushandeln so ist es auch
mit der Europäischen Union
Vielstimmigkeit und Diversität ist dabei
unsere Stärke
stumpf mit dem nationalen Kopf durch die
Wand zu wollen oder vielmehr Fakten frei
mit diesem an die Wand zu schlagen ist
weder eine gute Strategie noch eine
konstruktive Politik
und es tut auch schon meistens beim
Zuschauen weh die Europäische Union wird
beständig von uns neu gestaltet und
hoffentlich Schritt für Schritt
verbessert und den jeweils aktuellen
Gegebenheiten angepasst wenn Kritik aber
in Hass umschläfen alles konstruktive
vermissen lässt und es nicht um eine
Verbesserung sondern einfach nur noch um
die Zerstörung geht dann ist ein Punkt
erreicht wo wir hier in unserem
Parlament in unserem Land in Europa und
in Brüssel für eines der stärksten
friedensprojekte kämpfen müssen
nicht kämpfen wie die Ukraine mit
schweren Waffen gegen einer gressor von
außen kämpfen muss sondern von innen
heraus kämpfen mit Überzeugung Fakten
und den Möglichkeiten die ein freies
miteinander bieten
Werte Kollegin nur in einem freien und
diversen miteinander werden wir uns für
eine gelingende Zukunft aufstellen
können in der Europäischen Union in der
wir unsere Konflikte regelbasiert und
ohne einen nationalistisches ich zuerst
lösen können
und manchmal
manchmal sind es eben vermeintlich
kleine juristische Maßnahmen die einen
nicht unwesentlichen Anteil an einem
Gelingen eines großen Kampfes für den
Frieden in Europa haben danke viel
das Wort erhält Katharina dos Santos
Vince für die cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen mit Putins Teil
mobil machen vor einer Woche sowie den
scheinreferenten in den von Russland
besetzten Gebieten hat der russische
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine eine
neue Stufe erreicht als Reaktion darauf
hat die EU-Kommission gestern ein
Vorschlag für ein weiteres
Sanktionspaket gegen Russland vorgelegt
enthalten sind unter anderem weitere
Importbeschränkungen im Wert von um 7
Milliarden Euro sowie die
Rechtsgrundlage für einen preisdeckel
für Ölimporte aus Russland
neben neuen sanktionspaketen bedarf es
aber jedoch vor allem auch endlich eine
effektiveren Durchsetzung der bereits
bestehenden Sanktionen Sophie eine
Ahnung von Verstößen
aktuell bestehen zwischen den
sanktionsregimen der einzelnen
EU-Mitgliedsstaaten signifikante
Unterschiede was deren Wirkkraft
insgesamt deutlich abschwächt so handelt
es sich in einigen Mitgliedsstaaten bei
Verstößen im ordnungswidrigkeitenbereich
in anderen Ländern um schwere Straftaten
die mit langen Freiheitsstrafen geahndet
werden
angesichts dieses unterschiedlichen
Umgangs der Mitgliedsstaaten mit
Sanktionen ist es höchste Zeit das
sanktionsstrafrechts auf EU-Ebene zu
harmonisieren und so gewisse
Mindeststrafen bei Verstößen in allen
EU-Mitgliedsstaaten zu gewährleisten wir
müssen
wir müssen als EU einheitlich und stark
reagieren können jede Umgehung von
Sanktionen jedes Schlupfloch schwächt
die Sicherheit die Verhandlungsbasis und
letztendlich auch die Reputation der EU
und jedes Mitgliedsstaat selbst
grundsätzlich liegt das Strafrecht in
der Kompetenz der Mitgliedstaaten
allerdings darf die EU nach 83 Absatz 1
AUV Mindestvorschriften von Straftaten
in Strafen mit besonders schwerwiegenden
kriminalitätsbereichen festlegen die
eine grenzüberschreitende Dimension
haben das gilt zum Beispiel schon für
den Bereich der Geldwäsche wodurch
komplexe grenzüberschreitende
Verflechtungen eine länderübergreifende
Strafverfolgung und Zusammenarbeit
sinnvoll und notwendig ist im Mai diesen
Jahres hat die EU-Kommission den
Vorschlag für einen Beschluss des Rates
vorgelegt der auch das
sanktionsstrafrecht umfasst und aufgrund
seiner grenzüberschreitenden Dimensionen
in die Liste der kriminalitätsbereiche
aufzunehmen ist aus meiner Sicht ein
absolut wichtiger und richtiger Schritt
mir ist es an dieser Stelle aber noch
mal wichtig zu betonen dass der Deutsche
Bundestag sich auch in kurzer Zeit
intensiv in dieses Thema eingearbeitet
hat und zu den Themen beraten hat sowohl
in unserer Fraktion als auch in den
entsprechenden Gremien zuletzt gestern
im Europaausschuss und am Montag in der
öffentlichen Anhörung so nicht stehen
sondern Platz nehmen
so das war Katharina dos Santos Vince
hier in der
Debatte zu der Harmonisierung der
sanktionsdurchsetzung in der
Europäischen Union und diese Debatte ist
eigentlich vorbei aber der
Tagesordnungspunkt ist noch nicht vorbei
denn die Abgeordneten wollten dann über
diesen Gesetzentwurf abstimmen
allerdings wurde die Beschlussfähigkeit
des Parlaments von der afd-fraktion
angezweifelt und das bedeutet
hammelsprung
auch das er wurde schon häufiger
eingeübt die Abgeordneten verlassen alle
den Saal und kommen dann einzeln rein
und werden dabei
gezählt und sie sehen ist der Plenarsaal
ist ist sehr gut gefüllt denn die
meisten Abgeordneten selbst wenn sie
nicht in der Debatte sind arbeiten
natürlich dann doch hier in Ausschüssen
in Sitzungen die nicht öffentlich sind
oder in ihren Büros und können deswegen
oft sehr schnell dann hier in den
Sitzungssaal Island wenn so ein
hammelsprung nötig wird
wir warten hier noch auf das Ergebnis
des Bundestags Vizepräsidentin Yvonne
ammaquas jetzt eigentlich gleich
verkünden wollte denn das geht er ja
relativ schnell hier das Design
Dienerinnen und saldina ihre gezählten
Ergebnisse hier weitergeben können und
auch weil es eben doch in der
Vergangenheit noch so einige
hammelsprünge schon gab ist man dort
eigentlich mittlerweile recht
geübt da drin
die meisten hammelsprünge in einer
Wahlperiode gab es übrigens nicht in
letzter Zeit in der 19 Wahlperiode 2017
bis 2021 gab es 13 aber das wurde schon
einmal übertroffen in der 17 Wahlperiode
die von 2009 bis 2013 ging gab es
insgesamt 16 hammelsprünge und das ist
laut Bundestag damit der Spitzenreiter
bei der Anzahl der
hammelsprünge das Ergebnis der
Abstimmung durch Auszählung der Stimmen
über den über die Beschlussfähigkeit und
den Gesetzentwurf der Bundesregierung
in der zweiten Beratung auf Drucksache
34 41 bekannt geben abgegebene Stimmen
410 mit ja haben gestimmt
367 Abgeordnete und mit Nein haben
gestimmt 38 Abgeordnete Enthaltungen
fünfter Gesetzentwurf ist damit in
zweiter Beratung
angenommen und wir kommen in die dritte
Beratung und die Schlussabstimmung und
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen sich zu
erheben
das ist sie die Regierungskoalition und
die cdu/csu-fraktion wer stimmt dagegen
das ist
Fraktion der AFD und die Linke wer
enthält sich
dann ist der Gesetzentwurf damit
angenommen
[Applaus]
also das Parlament ist hier
beschlussfähig
Mitglieder des Hauses müssen anwesend
sein damit das Parlament
beschlussfähig ist
das Protokoll der Rede von Leni
breymaier noch mal zukommen lassen
weil ich ein Hinweis bekommen habe dass
es eine
Äußerung des Abgeordneten Martin
Reichert Gabe gab ein Zwischenruf
und sie haben sich hier reinquutiert sie
sind doch gar nicht qualifiziert das ist
eine beleidigende Äußerung der Kollegin
breimeier die ich hier mit Rüge und
bitte sie
[Applaus]
das nächste Mal auf diese beleidigen
Äußerungen zu verzichten sonst wird es
das nächste Mal ein Ordnungsruf und mit
Ordnungsgeld vielen Dank wir gehen
weiter in der Tagesordnung und ich rufe
also das hier war noch mal abschließend
zu der Nachhaltigkeitsdebatte die heute
morgen war während der Rede der SPD
Abgeordneten Leni breymaier gab es eben
diesen Zwischenruf von Martin Reichert
aus der afd-fraktion und diesen
Einwurf hat nun Yvonne marquas eben hier
gerü